地球のみんな隧道リーグくるか地鶏俺はねあんまり好きじゃないネジ通りここでカメラ
を自分に向けて
なんかね地鶏嫌いなんですよねかもんね気持ち悪い僕らの自撮りがちょっとねあんまり
好きじゃないんですけども
スマホのカメラスマホのカメラあると思います精巧なカメラの機能を発車っと取ります
と写真と人にわかると思いますけど客がねちょっとせないんですよね広くとりたいって
思った人行方1六角で画面がちょっと狭いんでもっと広ければいいなと思った人た
3いると思うそんな君たちに今日は朗報だフッ素で買ってきましたこちら各種スマート
フォン対応の木優クリップでん絶対言えばスマホにこれでつけるレンズみたいなんです
レンズの根がかったひろはるんですよこれなんか魚眼と金子ワイドな画面とかになるね
普通に iphone とかでとるとこ a 風邪なんですけどもこれをつけるとこう
いうふうに拾っくれるとこういうとても優れたものが今売って
います凄い過ごし防寒用ご先祖ついたロリ系写真撮っています
うっ
あああ画角は全然広くなりますこれさえあればできちゃう広く取れると思うんですけど
俺は載っ
止まった広く取りたいお前たちもそうだなこんなこと機で3足して車まだまだどんどん
ですがあちら日に絨毯でもないから33添えて頑張っちゃう猛攻挑むだよ
でこれ一つだけですけどこれだけの画角でトレーナーがこの魚眼レンズを断ったんだ
実ソルトを除きスマートフォンの限界までの画角の広さになると僕は思ったので今回
スマートフォン用脚でヒロあるレンズを国を準備しました
が欠けの広がるレンズを重ねて置いていくわけですよそうすると食べなんですけどもう
させ一枚撮ったらでも360度カメラみたいになると思うんですよ山強いない漏れの
第六感がそう言ってるからとりあえずレンズでもいたしましょう
問題はこれを頭って重ねるからですねこれ重ねてっていうか
のきた人は皆きたとはこれが最高だぐさーこれからスマートはもうこの連山も滅多に
見れませんからねあーあんびしゃもんトリバチ当たりましたこれがスマートフォンの
最高峰の価格ですご覧くださいできます
はいチーズ
その写真は
なぜか周りが黒く
映ってはいけないものがあ
映ってい
ヴァージンだぞと暗い部分多いたくても魚眼レンズダメなんだろうってねちょっと魚眼
センター失敗襲うんですけど次は何んで世界西方向のポッチがい最高峰の画角を見せて
あげましょう
まあこれが普通とちょっと器デバイダー練度をつけるとこうなります
広いくれちゃうワイドレンズならひょっとしたら黒い部分が少なくなりそうなので
ちょっとバイトラインをかける5でやってみましょう
これは何か
カフェでふとかで重ねた方がいいでるなこれやばいはこっちてればこれはやばいよは
完全いきました皆スマートこんなレンズ見たことありますか
もう一眼レフみたいな感じですねこれ本の必要
早速撮ってみましょうはいちーず不
ん
def